we're asked to find 10 to the 1.5th
power using a calculator round your
answer to the nearest hundredth so let's
get our calculator out and it'll be a
little bit different depending on the
type of calculator you're using but i'm
just going to use the ti 85 right over
here and there's actually a couple of
ways to do it you could literally just
type in 10
to the that little carrot sign right
there means to the
1.5 power
and so we could get
31.62 they said what to the hundredths
place so 31.62 the other way you could
do it is you could use the essentially
what's the inverse of the log button
right over here so if you do second log
because log is base 10 it immediately
goes 10 to the and we do 1.5 again that
seems a little bit more cumbersome
though because you have to press that
orange button all that you get the same
answer so 31 if we round to the nearest
hundreds 31.62 because the thousands
place is less than five so we round down
31.62
so we get 10 to the 1.5 power is
approximately equal to 31.62 when we
round to the nearest hundredths